Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in Elwajis
And we are in the book of purification.
We have now reached to
which we will begin today inshall
[Silence]
purification is of two types.
Purification with water and purification
with
with by way of
[Silence]
I went on autopilot there.
So he cites the near the verse of verse
number six.
He says that pure dust
is acts as a purification for the Muslim
even if he does not have access for wa
to water for 10 years. This is of course
a hypothetical but this is what the
prophet sallallah
says.
Now, in which instances
is it permissible
for us to
purify ourselves by way of
which which are the ways or which are
the instances in which is appropriate?
that is that it is permissible
and of course it's obligatory upon the
Muslim to use when unable to you know
purify himself or herself with water
that a person use
either because they do not have water
they do not have access to water they
are there is some kind of harm that will
come to them or affliction if they use
water
and this could be for a number of
reasons Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he
tells us
in this earlier verse verse number six
of and the verse mentioning
he says
He says if you do not have or do not
find water. Now this is the purpose the
main reason that Allah mentions and he
mentions it in this way and chooses this
reason because this is going to be the
most common across the board. When is a
person most likely to need to resort to
aum if they don't have water?
But the spirit of the verse articulates
that the person cannot find water. The
person cannot access water that he's
found. The person is going to
has to go through you know some kind
of mortal danger right or physical
danger
in order to access water. The person
is has some kind of illness that
prevents him from using water. A person
is unable to reach water. Whatever it
is, the point is is that a person is
unable to access water or access the use
of water. The person then uses.
He says,
[Silence]
Hussein narrates to us that once we were
with the messenger of Allah
sallallah.aii wasallam upon a journey
and he led the people in prayer
and then afterwards there was a man that
was off to the side. He had not prayed
with the companions
and it was clear that he was not
participating and so the messenger of
Allah sai wasallam asked him what you
know what's stopping you from praying
with us he said I am in a state of
janaba and there's no water there is no
water notice here how he says there is
no water there in in the desert.
Correct. They're traveling. Correct. Is
it conceivable that they are traveling
through the desert with zero water? Zero
water. No water. There's water. But
what's meant is that there's no water
for woo. There's no there's no water not
for woo but for bathing in this
instance. Right? So they only have
drinking water.
And this is another instance in which a
person makes the emblem. They have only
drinking water. Not enough. There's not
any more water coming and they're
traveling and they only have enough to
secure their to secure their you know
to secure their health to secure their
life with water. What in this case do
they do make
right?
And so the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam
said to this man,
"Upon you is to make is to make upon you
is the use of dust."
And we'll get into the parameters of
what is. He says because this is going
to suffice you. This narration is in
Bkari Muslim.
for.
[Silence]
He says Jab here narrates a narration
that yes it is cited in the books of
form in the chapters ofum and so forth.
However, there is a much broader lesson
for us to learn.
He says, "We went out for on a journey."
Him and other companions
went out on a journey. probably most
likely one of the
or possibly one of the numerous
one of the numerous marches that the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam sent out
upon his enemies but traveling was
common in Medina in and out and people
were going to and fro for their
livelihood etc. And so a man amongst us,
a rock fell onto his head, split his
head open.
You're traveling on a,
you know, between mountains. You're
going between,
you know, between two mountains, rocks
falling on your head is extremely
common, right? As a matter of fact,
people that live in these regions, they
know. I personally grew up in these
regions, you know, to always when you
walk to not make too much noise so that
you can listen for rocks falling, right?
And so this man as he was going, a rock
fell down, hit him in his head and
caused him a very serious head injury.
And so he asked and then after this
incident
he
went to sleep and he had a wet dream.
So now he's in Geneva
and so he asked his companions. His
companions here are compan Sahabah,
right? They're companions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Keep that in
mind. These are not just anybody. These
are companions.
And so he asked some of his
companions, "Do you all think that there
might be an excuse for me to make
in this instance instead of bathing due
to my head injury?" And they said, "We
don't know of any permissibility for you
to use
in this instance
when you have water available to your
use." Right? And so the man made
and then the man died from making his,
right? Whatever the reason was, the
water got into his
into his u
thing or or maybe some kind of cold or
something. Allah, but the man died and
it was clear that he died subsequent
injury when water was applied so heavily
to his head and to his and to his
body. And so when we return back to the
messenger of Allah sallaihi wasallam he
was told about this incident.
And so what was his response? The
messenger of Allah sallall.aii wasallam
said they killed him.
They killed him.
May Allah
may Allah
fight them or kill them. And this
this statement,
this is a figure of speech, right? It's
not a direct dua from the prophet Sam
against them that they die. But it's a
figure of speech that the you know
the Arabs used. They would say things
like
Right? They used to say things that
as probably every culture and language
has some sayings this or figures of
speech. He says why didn't they ask if
they didn't know better? if they didn't
know.
He said because the
cure to the ailment of ignorance is
the question. A question that is the
cure,
the antidote to the illness of
ignorance.
But the word is not just ignorance but
it's ignorance in the context of
illness.
And so ignorance is a disease.
He says here, "Why didn't they ask
if they didn't know?" Because the
antidote to the illness and the
affliction of ignorance is a question.
He said it was merely enough for him to
make to this narration is in a sunna.
Now, if we look at this narration,
there's a number of things we can
we can deduce. These are companions.
But are all companions the same? No.
They're the same to us in the sense that
they are companions of the messenger of
Allah. Similar to how the prophets are
the same to us
in the sense that they are all
messengers or prophets of Allah. We do
not distinguish between them in that
sense. But with Allah are all messengers
the same? No, right. They are of
different levels and different statures.
And likewise the companions, they are of
different levels. You have those who are
the direct companions, the inner circle,
the outer circle, the scholars and the
layman, the regular folks. And so these
men, they were not scholars. They were
not able to make it. These people were
not able to answer the question. But
notice that they answered the question
with knowledge, didn't they? Because
they said
you have to make or you have to make
that's something that they know from the
Quran, right? that if a person is in
janaba you have to make that's knowledge
and they also know that is something
when you cannot you do not have access
to water as the Quran says and spells
out that's knowledge right but it's
incomplete knowledge
it's knowledge removed from context and
this is what distinguishes scholarship
from the illusion of knowledge it's not
just the memorization of facts. It's not
even having just just having an
evidence. That's not enough. That's not
enough.
Knowledge is not the ability to
distinguish between right and wrong.
Knowledge is the ability to distinguish
between that which is right and that
which is less right and that which is
more right. and the ability to
distinguish between that which is wrong
and that which is worse and that which
is less wrong. Right? The shades, the
nuances. That's what knowledge is.
These men, they didn't have that, but
they answered the question anyways,
didn't they? That's a crime. That's a
crime.
They are guilty of that crime. And so
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
very upset with this. Why? Because there
are other companions Jaba himself
who are much more knowledgeable
than these individuals.
They should have said
we know that under normal circumstances
a must a person must make
and if they don't have access to water
they must make the yl under normal
circumstances. However clearly you have
circumstances that are not normal. We
don't have an evidence for your
situation. Ask someone else. If he would
have went through all of the companions
in that camp and none of them was able
to answer his question, what's the worst
that would happen? Nothing. Because they
have the source eventually when they go
back to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam, he'll ask. And so it's his
responsibility to do his best under
those circumstances.
However, for a person to answer, and
this is a disease that you'll see very
often,
an issue will be brought up and then
brothers that are there, they'll say,
"Well, you know what? I know, but you
know," and then they give a disclaimer
afterwards. I think that you should do
this or that or this or that. But then
again, I'm not a scholar. Well, if
you're not a scholar, why did you answer
the question? Well, I didn't answer
technically. I was just giving my
opinion. Why?
So, you want the praise if you get it
right, but you want the exit and the
back door to get away if you get it
wrong. So, you want all the glory of
knowledge, but you want none of the
responsibility or liability of
knowledge. Is this is what we're doing?
This is a disease. And that's why the
greatest lesson or one of the greatest
lessons that any student of knowledge
learns after
learningahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
is
and there is an interesting phenomenon
where people have studied for 10 or 15
years and they still haven't learned
this lesson they still don't know how to
say
they are ignorant in in this sense
because true knowledge is knowing your
own limitations.
That's what knowledge is. It is the
hallmark of a strong mind.
The mind which knows its own
limitations.
[Silence]
Turn this fence.